so right here we've listed two
quantities or two fluid volumes right
over here in terms of gallons one gallon
and two gallons and what i want to do in
this video is try to convert this
quantity of fluid this volume of fluid i
want to convert it into these other
units within the us customary system so
encourage you to pause the video and
first try to do the one gallon try to
convert it into quarts pints cups and
fluid ounces
well one gallon is equal to four quarts
is equal to four quarts so we can just
multiply by four
one quart is equal to two pints so we
can multiply this
by two so four quarts each of them are
two pints four times two gets us two
eight pints
each pint is equal to two cups so we
have eight pints each of them are equal
to two cups we're going to have
16 cups
and then finally if we're converting
from a cup to a fluid ounce each cup is
eight fluid ounces so if we have 16 cups
it's going to be 16 times eight let's
see 8 times 8 is 64 and it's going to be
twice that that's going to be
fluid ounces
now let's do the same thing with two
gallons try to convert that into quarts
pints cups and fluid ounces i encourage
you to pause the video and try it on
your own first
well same idea one gallon is
one gallon is equivalent to four quarts
so two gallons are going to be two times
four quarts or eight quarts
each quart is two pints so if we want to
go from quarts to pints we'd want to
multiply by 2 so this is going to be 16
pints and then each pint is 2 cups
so multiplying if so i have 16 of them
then that's going to be 32 cups and then
finally each cup is 8 ounces
each cup is eight ounces 32 times eight
is going to be let's see it's gonna be
256 and notice something here when we
went from one gallon to two gallons we
essentially increased the quantity of
gallons by two or we multiplied by two
and you see that across the board here
four is is going from four quarts to
eight quarts this is going from eight
pints to 16 pints this is going from 16
cups to 32 cups going from 128 fluid
ounces to 256 where essentially when you
increase the volume in gallons by a
factor of 2 you're of course going to
increase the volume in any unit you
measure it in by a factor of 2.